elle des policiers en colère ils ont
battu le pavé aujourd'hui devant les
locaux de la sûreté départementale à
viroflay ils étaient une centaine dans
la ligne de mire la réorganisation de la
ddsp la direction départementale de la
sécurité publique dans les yvelines en
plateau l'oif travers bonsoir également
maryline bereaud bonsoir un joueur vous
êtes responsable zonal donc pour tout le
secteur ile de france qui nous concerne
et puis vous êtes délégué départemental
alors ce qui vous concerne
on va évoquer cette question mais
auparavant un reportage c'était ce matin
cette mobilisation
on va voir comment vous étiez un
mobiliser reportages de la rédaction de
clerck en billets julie rocha et elodie
mois le froid et la neige n'ont pas eu
raison de leur mobilisation
une centaine de policiers manifester ce
matin et sous les flocons devant les
locaux de la sécurité départementale
lacoste leur ras-le-bol
le projet de réorganisation de la police
qui prévoit la suppression de la brigade
anticriminalité autrement dit la bague
désir in ce projet avant tout c'est la
dissolution d'unité qui interpelle
annuellement plus de 400 individus
sachant qu'un délinquant ne connaît ne
commet pas un seul délit il en commet
plusieurs donc c'est une conséquence
fâcheuse pour ce pour ce département
et puis aussi il faut prendre en compte
bien évidemment et bien l'intérêt de mes
collègues qui se trouvent aujourd'hui
derrière moi tous ses collègues de de la
bac départementale qui ont rejoint
durant des années et à qui on va
demander de demande tout simplement
quitter cette unité est allé travailler
vers d'autres cieux vers d'autres cieux
c'est à dire vers d'autres services dans
les commissariats locaux
la brigade des stupéfiants des yvelines
seraient également concernées en tout
une quarantaine de fonctionnaires un
moyen de grossir les effectifs des
paulistes proximité sans créer de
nouveaux postes
si les policiers n'ont pas le droit de
grève leur solidarité a permis une forte
mobilisation ce qu'ils demandent
aujourd'hui c'est d'être entendu la
première se des solutions se serait déjà
de nous de nous écouter de nous
convoquer et de nous dire exactement où
ils veulent où ils veulent en venir
puisque nous sommes bien évidemment
attaché à une meilleure et une qualité
du service public mais que ça ne se
fasse pas au détriment de nos collègues
le directeur départemental de la
sécurité publique a reçu une délégation
en fin de matinée le jm mentionné sur
les slogans n'a pas souhaité s'exprimer
devant nos caméras
il attend tout comme ses policiers une
réaction du préfet on va là pour cette
mobilisation finalement assez rare des
forces de l'ordre on n'a pas l'habitude
de vous voir dans la rue manifester
vous avez été entendue finalement vous
avez une réunion un rendez vous en
préfecture alors dans un premier temps
effectivement on peut considérer qu'on a
été entendu puisque le directeur
départemental de la sécurité publique
nous a effectivement reçu
pour justement parler du projet puisque
ce qu'on lui reprochait de n'avoir pas
du tout été concertée sur ce sujet donc
à une première partie effectivement là
qui est réalisé avec un calendrier qui
devrait nous être transmis par rapport
aux négociations par rapport au comité
technique départemental qui va entériner
ces différentes restructurations par
condor nous être assurés alors
finalement en partie parce qu'il ya
quand même un le premier représentant de
l'état qui est monsieur jo le préfet du
département qui pour l'instant ne nous a
pas enfin nous a pas donné de rendez
vous donc on attend avec impatience pour
pouvoir de nouveau exprimé ce que nous
avons à dire on va re préciser les
enjeux justement de cette réorganisation
si je me reprenne et six jeux si je me
trompe c'est suppression de la bac
anticriminalité suppression
éventuellement aussi de la brigade des
stupéfiants ça au niveau départemental
pour ensuite éventuellement redéployer
ses unités sur un plan plus local
c'est bien ça alors au niveau de la
brigade anticriminalité départementale
c'est la dissolution est donc en ce qui
concerne la sûreté départementale des
stupéfiants c'est une restructuration
parce qu'à travers ce projet de service
cette réforme et cette réorganisation je
dirais territoriales et des services
aussi il ya une forte inquiétude de la
part de nos collègues parce que nous
avons des questions qui restent sans
réponse et on parle et notre
administration parler et la direction
départementale des yvelines parle d'une
restructuration mais avec des effectifs
constants donc l'inquiétude de nos
collègues parce que il y à un
accompagnement aussi je dirais
professionnel il ya un accompagnement
aussi sur une vie sociale et de
collègues se demandent ce qui va se
passer de même pour pour eux mais quand
on entend parler justement d'un
resserrement un niveau plus local est ce
que c'est pas quelque chose de plus
positif pour être plus proche de la
population plus proche des différents
problèmes rencontrés dans la réalité
c'est qu'effectivement les entités dont
on parle ici ils sont remises en cause
sont les entités départementales
donc l'idée qui est émis
en fait tout simplement de les recentrer
sur des secteurs particuliers alors si
l'idée peut paraître bonne effectivement
a priori nous elle nous inquiète parce
que ça ne se fait sans apport
d'effectifs c'est à dire qu'en fait on
déshabille des services entiers pour
pouvoir les réinjecter et ça nous
rappelle malheureusement lécher les
échecs de la police de proximité mise en
place en 1999 où c'était déjà le même
débat c'est à dire qu'on avait
effectivement mis en place des
structures spécifiques dans des zones en
des endroits dans des territoires
et il se trouve que voilà c'est pas
devenu quelque chose qui a perduré dans
le temps parce que il n'y a pas eu
d'accord d'effectifs y avait une et pas
une véritable volonté par rapport à ça
mais si en apport d'effectif ce serait
une bonne solution la police de
proximité si c'était un retour de la
police de proximité ce gars là on ne
parle pas de retour de police de
proximité puisque seul le terme plus
souvent employé le mot district
alisation donc la réalité est en fait qu
tivement de par exemple faire en sorte
que le poulet l'encours guyancourt
trappe bien puissent bénéficier d'un
surplus d'effectifs notamment en matière
de lutte contre les atteintes aux
personnes et
l'ugtt en général contre les
cambriolages donc essayer de faire en
sorte que les effectifs soient un peu
plus conséquent dans ces endroits là et
pour ces matières la haye la demande
aujourd'hui pour vous c'est quoi c'est
d'avoir des effectifs supplémentaires
complètement incomplètement c'est à dire
que on part du principe qu'on ne pourra
pas faire cette réforme avec des
effectifs comptent constants on n'y met
pas les moyens la réalité est là
aujourd'hui si on devait faire quelque
chose de très positif
il faut ce qu'on dit nous recentrer sur
le coeur de métier c'est à dire nous
enlever toutes les servitudes et toutes
les tâches annexes qui nous qui polluent
la vie des policiers tous les jours donc
là en l'occurrence et les gardes
hôpitaux les gardes de détenus
les transfèrements ce sont toutes ces
missions là qui aujourd'hui font que ben
voilà c'est peut-être moins opérationnel
que ce que voudrait notre administration
une centaine de policiers mobilisés ce
matin c'est suffisant selon vous est-ce
que vous avez été assez nombreux pour
vous faire entendre parce que vous
n'avez pas droit de grève
donc je leur précise c'est peut-être
qu'il complique aussi la tâche j'ai dit
mais on n'a pas droit de grève pour
autant on a le droit de manifester et en
l'occurrence ce matin une centaine de
personnes vu le temps neigeux c'était
pas si mal
on a obtenu entre guillemets quand même
le fait d'être reçus par monsieur
salanova et le but maintenant c'est
d'avoir effectivement peut-être sur les
prochaines étapes des certitudes quand
justement à ce qui va se dérouler
notamment les inquiétudes des collègues
c'est quelle compensation en fait pour
ceux qui vont être restructurés parce
que derrière ça va sans doute impliqué
des déménagements de familles entières
et que ça ben voilà ce programme il y a
il est rentré il ya des enfants qui sont
à l'école et c'est sur c'est dans ces
domaines là notamment qu'on veut en
discuter au quotidien justement de ces
problématiques là des difficultés tout
devrait aller rencontrer parce que comme
je le disais tout à l'heure les
collègues sont inquiets de ce
reclassement donc se demande
éventuellement est ce qu'on peut avoir
une prime je dirais de restructuration
est ce qu'il va y avoir un
accompagnement sur le plan financier
est-ce qu'il va y avoir des mutations en
dehors du département et du 78 parce que
ces policiers là de la brigade
anticriminalité départementale aspire
bien évidemment à un déroulement de
carrière dans des tirs et des unités
spécifiques et spéciale donc
éventuellement une forte réorganisation
et c'est ce qui vous inquiète vous
l'avez exprimé ce soir juste pour
conclure j'aimerais tout de même revenir
aussi sur sur le fait que la presse un
actuellement se fait vraiment l'écho du
blues du policier on en parle souvent il
ya eu au début du mois une enquête sur
le management et le stress au travail
qui a été rendu public et qui a été
menée par une unité de recherche du cnrs
de toulouse avec l'appui du syndicat
alliance justement 6000 policiers qui
ont répondu je veux donner quelques
chiffres
quelques résultats quelques conclusions
63% des sondés qui estiment que la
police ne valorise pas leur contribution
à l'accomplissement de sa mission avec
90% a réfuté en bloc l'idée selon
laquelle la police se soucie vraiment de
leur bien-être
ce sont des constats vraiment d'un mal
être qui s'exprime au quotidien sur le
terrain
aujourd'hui les choses ne vont pas bien
les policiers ne sont pas sereins la
réalité c'est que les les collègues qui
sont sur le terrain ont toujours
tendance à dire qu'on met effectivement
qu'on les montre du doigt et qu'on les
stigmatise ben voila quand il ya des
affaires qui défraient parfois la
chronique mais que systématiquement leur
travail n'est pas mis en valeur
voilà et que là il y a un véritable rôle
à jouer pour la hiérarchie intermédiaire
qui peut être se désintéresse
très clairement de cela d'où ce malaise
exprimé sur cette enquête relativement
indépendante puisque faut bien rappeler
qu'elle est réalisée non pas à la
demande d'un syndicat de policiers mais
bien bel et bien sûr une initiative
d'une tranche du cnrs du cnrs du côté de
toulouse tout à fait inclure la suite de
votre mouvement
notre mobilisation est attendue alors
d'autres mobilisations sont attendus
effectivement si monsieur le préfet du
département ne nous reçoit pas et ici
monsieur le directeur départemental de
la sécurité publique ne nous met pas
clairement un calendrier dans lesquels
on va pouvoir effectivement programmer
les négociations puis le comité
technique départemental qui entérinerait
ce qui serait choisi
mais avant tout on veut certains détails
effectivement qu aujourd'hui nous
conteste parce que il faut bien rappeler
quand même que ce matin c'était non à la
restructuration
merci à tous les deux d'être venu sur ce
plateau les forces de l'ordre qui sont
mobilisées contre cette réorganisation
d'une partie des services nous aurons
l'occasion de reparler au cours de nos
prochaines éditions merci à vous avant
de passer aux sports jour donne cette
information les difficultés qui vont
durer si vous empruntez la ligne de
train la verrière la défense la
circulation est interrompue
et ce pendant deux à trois semaines
voire même un mois c'est la conséquence
d'un incendie survenu ce week end au
poste de signalisation deux-sèvres
quelques précisions cinquante cinq mille
voyageurs sont concernés
depuis ce matin aucun train ne circule
sur la ligne e du transilien
cette ligne reliant la verrière à la
défense est fermé en raison d'un
incendie survenu dimanche à 4 heures du
matin à la station sèvres ville d'avray
de relais comment de la circulation à
sèvres ville d'avray
ce lundi seule la moitié des trains au
départ de versailles rive droite
circulent la ligne e -u quant à elle est
totalement condamné pour deux à trois
semaines
aucun bus supplémentaire ne sera mise en
service une solution insuffisante face
au volume d'usagé trop important la sncf
encourage les voyageurs à s'orienter
vers la ligne c du rer et le tramway t2
vers la défense pour l'heure aucune
mesure d'indemnisation n'est envisagée